alors question l'éducation nationale
s'est elle vraiment dégradée depuis le
début de la pandémie doit-on s'inquiéter
pour l'avenir de nos enfants les profs
français sont ils particulièrement
maltraitées c'est l'objet de notre
décryptage
est avec nous pour en parler ce soir
alain tailly co secrétaire du syndicat
snuipp fsu dans le nord bonsoir à
l'intérieu merci d'être avec nous france
quatre boeufs délégué départemental du
modem dans le nord est également bonsoir
à vous alors un mot tout d'abord
l'intérieur sur les mobilisations
syndicales avaient appelé 4-1
précisément appelé à battre le pavé pour
plusieurs mots d'ordre la gravité
finalement assez peu suivie
3,95 dans le primaire 619 pour le
software saas et les chiffres du
ministère ils sont un peu tout de même
nettement d'ailleurs supérieure du côté
des syndicats vous vous êtes déçus ou ça
ne veut rien dire finalement pour vous
non effectivement les chiffres seront
pas à la hauteur de ce qu'on aurait pu
espérer on va être honnête on aurait
aimé davantage mobilisés après
j'avais pas la première fois que on a
une pas une mobilisation à la hauteur de
ce qu'on pourrait espérer néanmoins
on aura d'autres occasions vous avez
parlé effectivement du 5 octobre donc
dans le cadre d'une intersyndicale
profit interprofessionnelle on sera de
nouveau dans la rue le mardi 5 octobre
france quarterbacks les profs 1 qui
entre autres un évoque des petits
salaires on les a entendu les conditions
de travail dégradées voir un mal-être
chez certains est-ce qu'ils ont raison
aujourd'hui de se mobiliser de faire
entendre leur voix selon vous
alors bon soir à vous madame tout n'est
jamais rose évidemment
mais je voudrais rappeler par exemple
les propos tout à fait
fondés que tenait monsieur beaupied
beach qui est ce le secrétaire général
du syndicat national des personnels de
direction de l'éducation nationale et
qui disait il y a de cela quelques jours
que en allemagne où les salaires des
enseignants sont très supérieurs à ce
qu'ils sont en france
il y a malgré tout des difficultés au
recrutement donc le salaire n'est pas le
seul élément qu'il convient d'améliorer
je ne conteste pas qu'il faille
d'améliorer mais il faut quand même
rappeler que les enseignants débutants
les jeunes enseignants ont gagné à peu
près 200 euros nets par mois entre
décembre 2016 et décembre 2021 donc il
ya eu quand même un certain effort et je
dois dire que j'étais un petit peu navré
de ce que j'entendais dans votre
reportage quand j'entends que
jean-michel plan caire est un ministre
réactionnaire je suppose enfin j'ai on a
l'impression que c'est simplement parce
que ils demandent que les élèves du
primaire sachent lire écrire et compter
qu'il devient tout à coup un ministre
réactionnaire ça me fait de la peine
parce que je suis depuis plus de 30 ans
enseignant aux facultés j'ai des
étudiants qui ont de grosses difficultés
d'écriture d'orthographe de grammaire et
lorsque je vois le ministre qui
s'attelle à cette tâche je pense qu'elle
est tout à fait importante et que
qu'elle n'est pas réactionnaires et de
la même manière lorsque des enseignants
disent on veut pas bosser pour toi
écoutez quand on est enseignant bosse
pas pour le ministre on bosse pour la
jeunesse on bosse pour l'avenir du pays
et je suis vous savez dans un une petite
vie je n'oserais pas le nom je me suis
renseigné tout à l'heure une petite
ville à côté doit il ya cinq écoles sur
cinq écoles il y avait aujourd'hui un
gréviste qui était un directeur d'école
en tout et pour tout et je moi je ne
manque jamais des gens qui font grève
parce que c'est respectable c'est une
liberté démocratique mais je suis
heureux de voir que la majorité des
enseignants sont conscients des enjeux
de la gravité de la situation et plano
plaisent de l'ordre de leur profession à
l'intérieu qu'est ce que ce qu'est ce
que vous répondez parce que
effectivement france
quattre baffes est un petit peu sur la
ligne en tout cas de luminy ce blanc car
qui dit
j'apporte la précision c'est pas vous
qui l'avez dit mais effectivement le
gouvernement c'est une revalorisation
historique qui a eu lieu cette année
d'accord pas d'accord avec ça et un thaï
e bonds talus excusez moi pardon excusez
moi depuis tout à l'heure j'ai hésité
avec ses deux ailes je vous remercie
alors dire plusieurs choses à répondre
bon alors mois pour répondre
effectivement mobilisation allez vous
avez raison monsieur +49 allait elle est
n'est pas la même partout sur l'ensemble
du territoire je pourrais prendre
l'exemple de la ville de roubaix où il
ya neuf écoles dans lesquelles on a dû
mettre en place le service minimum
d'accueil ça veut dire que dans ses neuf
écoles il est plus de 25% de grévistes
ça veut dire que il ya sans doute des
disparités il ya les endroits où est la
ville de roubaix est particulièrement
touché et marqué marque et socialement
et donc je pense que là le malaise
enseignant il se dit que s'expriment
différemment on fait en fonction des
territoires par rapport à la
mobilisation et au par rapport aux
salaires effectivement il ya une légère
amélioration pour les enseignants en
début de carrière il faut le reconnaître
la revalorisation historique dont on
parle elle ne peut pas considérer avec
la sueur historique elle concerne pour
l'instant les enseignants deuxième au
septième échelon c'est là qu'elle
concerne à peine un tiers des
enseignants et on l'a entendu tout à
l'heure c'est à peu près entre 30 et 40
euros par mois c'est à dire que c'est
pas suffisant pour rattraper la
situation
du salaire des enseignants en allemagne
alors effectivement des problèmes de
recrutement et qui ne sont pas forcément
liés au sel je suis entièrement d'accord
avec vous d'ailleurs j'ai même vous dire
quelque chose en fait on s'aperçoit que
nous syndicalement on a beaucoup de mal
à mobiliser les collègues quand on parle
de salaire parce que les collègues avec
qui on travaille ce sont pas des gens
qui décident de faire carrière pour
faire fortune c'est pas un métier où on
est riche on n'est à l'abri de la
fortune et de l'ain fortune quand on est
enseignant c'est à dire que
effectivement à une situation où on s'en
sort pas trop mal sauf que c'est de
moins en moins évident est la raison
pour laquelle il ya une crise de
recrutement c'est à dire que pour donner
un ordre d'idée
pour un poste dans ce concours de
professeur des écoles on avait il ya une
dizaine d'années on avait cinq candidats
aujourd'hui a plus que trois candidats
l'année dernière dans le département du
nord il ya 18 enseignants stagiaires
dans le premier degré qui ont
démissionné durant leur année de stage
c'est à dire qu'on arrive quasiment à 5%
c'est trop on le nombre de démissions a
été multipliée en dix ans a été
multiplié par quatre on arrive à
quasiment 1400 des missions par an c'est
trop et ça a des conséquences
sur le terrain parce que du coup
effectivement il nous manque des
personnels et puis ça a des conséquences
qu'en fait enfin c'est s'est traduit
quelque chose ça traduit un mal-être des
de nos collectes effectivement vous avez
raison mon à moi ça fait 21 ans que je
fais ce métier je l'aimais je
n'arrêterai pas l'année prochaine de
faire ce métier et on aspire tous à voir
progresser nos envies nos élèves le
problème c'est qu'on a l'impression que
on n'est pas suffisamment entendue on
n'a pas suffisamment de moyens pour leur
permettre de réussir alors on va
continuer ce débat avec quelques
chiffres 1 re gardiste ce petit
comparatif du portail stati star sur le
salaire des enseignants en europe on en
parle souvent de ce comparatif le
luxembourg garder est loin devant avec
l'allemagne sur les onze pays du
comparatif la français est en 9e
position et si l'on compare plus en
détail le salaire d'un enseignant du
secondaire c'est moitié moins entre la
france et l'allemagne que ce soit au
début de carrière ou après 15 ans
d'ancienneté une réaction peut-être
parce que quatre boeufs sur ces écarts
considérables
alors je repense que disait monsieur bob
québec qui vous savez réagissait en fait
à la proposition madame hidalgo de
doubler le salaire des enseignants et il
posait cette question intéressante qui
était mais quelles sont les
contreparties et il disait lui même que
les la charge de travail il n'était
peut-être pas la même dans notre pays
que dans d'autres pays alors encore une
fois moi je respecte infiniment les
enseignants je suis fils et petit fils
d'institutrice on n'entendra jamais
critiqué les enseignants et pendant le
confinement les parents d'élèves se sont
rendu compte à quel point c'était un
métier ingrat et difficile mais je crois
vraiment que et pour répondre à monsieur
une grande partie du mal être des
enseignants n'est pas une question de
revenus sécu scellier malheureusement à
la dureté les difficultés de notre
société qui se traduisent y compris dans
les écoles et là il faut arriver à faire
des écoles mais je sais que c'est
difficile des oasis ce qui est compliqué
c'est dans des quartiers qui sont eux
mêmes difficiles ou dans des files
difficile avec une population qui
s'appauvrit c'est évident mais je crois
que vraiment le salaire on peut poser la
question franchement aux enseignants
c'est à dire et je ne suis pas
sarkozyste comme l'ont été les des
membres du modem qui n'ont jamais été
sarkozyste paix est ce que les
enseignants veulent travailler plus pour
gagner plus voyez c'est à dire que ce
dessus et ce syndicaliste monsieur pop
qu'évite j'avais raison est-ce qu'en
allemagne il ne travaillerait pas plus
est ce qu'en france ils sont prêts à
travailler plus on n'a rien sans rien et
il faut savoir que en réalité il ya un
million deux cent mille
personnel dans l'éducation nationale et
on ne s'en rend pas compte mais chaque
somme qui individuellement est faible
pour chaque enseignant représente un
total considérable sur le plan
budgétaire et malheureusement le budget
n'est pas extensible à l'infini alors
justement dans le prolongement avant de
faire réagir à linthal eux je vous
propose d'écouter un économiste
christian saint-etienne qui était
d'ailleurs sur notre antenne mercredi ça
va rejoindre un petit peu son propos
monsieur 80 écouter les annonces que
votre journaliste devant la cour des
comptes a rappelé totalement délirante
par exemple d'hidalgo de doubler les
salaires des enseignants sans préciser
que par exemple dans les pays où les
salaires sont plus élevés les
enseignants notamment en allemagne ou
ailleurs accepte par exemple d'enseigner
deux matières alors qu'en france on
enseignants refusent d'enseignés plus de
2 many matière les syndicats s'y
opposent totalement les dans les autres
pays où les enseignants sont mieux payés
les ces enseignants acceptent également
de travailler davantage donc voilà on
parle de doubler les salaires sans
modification structurelle dans tous les
domaines c'est ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur ça vous inspire quoi ces
propos vous par exemple vous accepteriez
d'enseigner deux matières par exemple de
travailler plus on vous n'êtes pas du
tout d'accord effectivement avec ces
allégations de l'économie c'est de
monsieur quattro boeuf également
écouter me suis je suis professeur des
écoles je viens globalement goodyear
matière de fête de nature c'est donc ça
me fait doucement rire je pense qu'ils
parlent effectivement du collège et du
lycée un effectivement papa des pas des
instituteurs si vous posez la question
je vous réponds conduit en lycée pro les
enseignant en lycée pro ils ont dix
enseignes sont bivalent hills en scène
deux matières
c'est même jeu jeu effectivement on
pourra imaginer que ça puisse se faire
comme ça je pense que c'est
ça pas forcément de sens par rapport au
temps de travail ce que là effectivement
ni peut-être quinze ans s'ils ne
travaillent pas suffisamment le temps de
travail moyen d'un enseignant
dans le premier degré dans le second
degré correspond à 40 4 heures par
semaine je suis désolé mais ça fait 20
ans que je fais ce métier je vois pas
comment j'arriverai à travailler à
dégager du temps pour travailler
davantage jeu même en cherchant bien je
vois pas si on veut bien faire son
métier si on veut vraiment bien préparé
correctement les élèves et leur
permettre d'acquérir les compétences
pour devenir des citoyens éclairés ben
voilà il faut y passer du temps
il ya évidemment du temps en classe mais
c'est tout le temps qu'ils aient tout
temps qui a coté un enseignant dans le
premier degré il travaille 27 heures par
semaine sauf que ça c'est ça c'est juste
le temps le temps de présence à l'école
c'est à dire que tout le reste c'est du
temps qu'il n'ait pas mesuré cdu c'est
du travail invisible si vous voulez mais
on peut qu'on s'est promis ce pas
imaginez vous un enseignant de de petite
section moyenne section qui arriverait
le matin à 8h20 pour l'accueil des
élèves sans avoir préparé tous les
ateliers qui l'a après sa demande ça
demande du temps à côté donc il ya sap
il ya autre chose sur la difficulté du
métier mais je pense que monsieur 90 le
reconnaître c'est que passer une journée
avec
de six heures avec des enfants de trois
à quatre cinq six ans c'est très
fatigant c'est très fatigant et ça je
pense qu'il faut il faut pouvoir
longtemps et comme vous le disiez
pendant le confinement les parents se
sont rendu compte de la difficulté du
métier
effectivement d'avoir ingéré un groupe
d'enfants de 4 4 points 3 4 5 6 ans
toute la journée et donc il va falloir
leur trouver non seulement voilà
les faire progresser leur apprendre
quelque chose mais aussi faire vivre un
groupe un groupe d'enfants
ensemble apprendre à sociaux stabilisés
apprendra à travailler ensemble et tout
ça c'est difficile donc sur l'acquis
après sur le doublement des salaires la
fsu le syndicat auquel j'appartiens n'a
jamais réclamé le doublement des
salaires c'est une proposition d'anne
hidalgo donc moi effectivement on est
pour une revalorisation des salaires
mais comme je dis c'est pas forcément
l'alpha et l'oméga de notre métier c'est
parce qu'on cherche à dire ce qui nous
pose problème aujourd'hui ce qui posera
nous enseignants c'est les conditions de
travail qui sont difficiles je voudrais
quelques exemples le le fait qu' il ya
eu il ya des démissions et il ya des
collègues qui demandent des ruptures
comment celles actuellement on se
retrouve à faire la rentrée dans le
département du nord il nous manque ce
qui manque c'est l'inspecteur d'académie
qui le reconnaît le 3 septembre qui
manquent 54 personnes pour occuper
l'ensemble des postes dans le
département du nord le premier degré il
manque 54 personnes le jour de la
rentrée donc ce sont des remplaçants qui
vont boucher les trous sauf que ces
rotations la besoins au fur et à mesure
de l'année parce qu'il est collectons
malade est aujourd'hui monsieur
l'inspecteur d'académie leur thé au cdn
de la semaine dernière le 17 septembre
il reconnaît qu'il y a environ 130
enseignants non remplacés
toutes les semaines dans le département
du nord donc ça c'est fatigant parce que
du coup comment elles comment ça se
passe les enfants ne peuvent pas être la
partie ils sont quand même répartis dans
des bulles donc on se retrouve avec des
classes qui seront plus chargées on se
retrouve avec avoir à gérer ses
problèmes de non remplacement et puis à
des conséquences par exemple on parle du
doublement le doublement le dédoublement
des classes entre en cp enseignants en
éducation prioritaire une des mesures
phares du gouvernement par deux du
capitanat macro
et 2 et 2 blancs car si un enseignant un
de ces deux enseignants de céder les
deux s'étaient adoucis nains des deux
qui est absent le dédoublement hills à
nu en fait va demander à l'enseignant
d'avoir ingéré le lancement par an
peuvent le constater un pas beaucoup de
remplacements en tout cas quand on est
dans l'école publique ça c'est sûr a du
primaire jusqu'au lycée
dernière question justement sur cette
proposition d'anne hidalgo on ne
rappelle évidemment si une fallait
qu'elle est candidate à l'élection
présidentielle qui proposons de doubler
ses salaires france 4 9 ckoi c'est une
proposition démagogique ou aux réalistes
enfin où est ce qu'on peut trouver cet
argent finalement ça paraît réaliste
pour vous un enseignant me disais tout à
l'heure que ça représentait à peu près
150 milliards d'euros sur cinq ans oui
c'est complètement farfelu
voyez ça rappelle un peu les
propositions de françois hollande quand
il annonçait une taxation des ddd grands
revenus qui a été retoquée par les eaux
du riz diction et sur lequel elle
laquelle il a dû complètement reculer
c'est à dire que et et ses cibles et moi
je suis un vieux militant un vieux
militants centristes
j'essaie toujours de ne jamais rien
promettre que je ne puisse pas tenir
parce que promettre n'importe quoi c'est
ouvrir grande la porte au populisme
parce que ça exaspère et je regrette que
madame hidalgo se livrent à ce genre de
surenchère parce qu'effectivement c'est
un faisable d'ailleurs les syndicats
ogbl n'y crois pas heureusement c'est
infaisable et c'est de nature comme
toujours à désespérer à mettre en colère
et c'est ce qui conduit aujourd'hui
hélas au désaveu des politiques à à
l'abstention massive au vote populiste
et je regrette que madame hidalgo se
fasse le fourrier du populisme je le
regrette vraiment merci en tout cas à
tous les deux franz quatreboeufs à
linthal d'avoir était avec moi en direct
sur arte france pour ce face à face
merci